امريكا صديقتنا وحليفتها ولكن نظام بايدن
يجب ان يتوقف عن الضغط علينا اخبار العالم
بايجاز من غرفه اخبار الجزيره اهلا بكم
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي يواصل جولته في
المنطقه نتنياهو يرفض اي خطوه لانهاء
الحرب قبل القضاء على حماس وبن جفير يطالب
اداره بايدن بوقف ضغوطها في حين اكد لابيد
استعداده لتامين حمايه للحكومه اذا غادرها
بن جفير م تريتش ورؤساء مجالس مستوطنات
غلاف غزه يحتجون امام مكتب نتنياهو على
المعامله التي يتلقاها السكان والخطه
المقترحه لعودتهم المزيد من اخبار حرب غزه
تجدونها في رابط اسفل التعليق الاول وزير
الداخليه التركي يعلن مقتل مسلحين حاولا
مهاجمه قصر العدل تشيان في اسطنبول واصابه
خمسه اشخاص بينهم شرطيان مضيفا ان الهجوم
الذي وصفه بالارهابي نفذته جبهه حزب
التحرير الشعبي
الثوري الحكومه السودانيه تعلن ان عدد
النازحين في تسع ولايات بلغ اكثر من 11
مليون نازح مؤكده ان اكثرهم تضررا هم
شريحتا النساء والاطفال في غضون ذلك قالت
منظمه اطباء بلا حدود ان طفلا واحدا على
الاقل يموت كل ساعتين في مخيم زمزم الذي
يعد الاكبر والاقدم في
البلاد ثمان شركات معنيه بالتكنولوجيا من
بينها مايكروسوفت توقع ميثاقا لبناء ذكاء
اصطناعي اكثر اخلاقيه تعهدوا من خلاله
بالاضطلاع التام بدورهم في حمايه حقوق
الانسان في تصميم الذكاء الاصطناعي
وتطويره وشرائه وبيعه واستخدامه يلزمهم
الميثاق بوضع اجراءات تحقق لتقويم مخاطره
وتصحيح اثاره
السلبيه الى
اللقاء